Bienvenidos a este especial sobre la
extrema derecha en Brasil yo soy Alba
Santana y les voy a acompañar en este
análisis sobre cómo el país pasó de un
gobierno de izquierdas o progresista a
uno de ultraderecha y Qué factores
contribuyeron en esta transición y es
que a pesar de que Jair bolsonaro ha
perdido las elecciones de este 2022 la
extrema derecha sigue muy Viva en el
país 58 millones de personas votaron por
él frente a los 60 que le dieron la
presidencia a Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
veamos cómo se llegó hasta esto
eran tiempos convulsos en Brasil en 2013
lo que inició como una ola de protestas
en contra de la subida del precio del
transporte público el gasto en la copa
de confederaciones y el mundial de 2014
terminó escalando hasta el punto en el
que todo ese descontento se centró en
una sola figura la entonces presidenta
Dilma Rousseff que en su segundo mandato
empezó a ver cómo su popularidad caía en
picada
somos nosotros quienes ganamos en
seguridad e infraestructuras que son
fundamentales son fundamentales pero ese
descontento que se había cocinado poco a
poco Durante los últimos años sólo iba
en aumento y en 2015 en la situación del
país pareció tocar fondo en lo económico
Brasil estaba en plena recesión con un
ajuste fiscal el pib desplomándose y el
desempleo subiendo En lo político el
partido de los trabajadores estaba en
caída libre y los casos de corrupción
entre ellos el famoso lavallato
empezaban a amontonarse sobre el
escritorio de russeff pero la situación
todavía podía empeorar más y lo hizo las
protestas y acusaciones de corrupción
contra Dilma nunca probadas acabaron con
su destitución un contexto de
inestabilidad del que algunos salieron
beneficiados como el ultraderechista
Jair bolsonaro o congresista y senador
poco conocido hasta su famoso discurso a
favor del impeachment
procedente de una zona rural de Sao
Paulo el ex militar se iba a convertir
en alguien muy importante en el país
buzonaro hace un discurso votando por
alguien pachman de Dilma
hablando bien o sea homenajeando a al
Coronel utra que ha sido un gran
torturador en la dictadura brasileña
puedo sonaro se quedó muy conocido y
mucha gente en redes sociales empezó a
llamar
y a crear grupos en su favor porque creo
que la gente está tan enojada Que ya no
querían
la disputa política saludable querían la
exterminación del otro bolsonaro
elevaría su popularidad enarbolando un
discurso de extrema derecha con el que
muchos se sintieron identificados
ideales que los llevaron a convertirse
en presidente en 2018
cambiando el curso político de Brasil
pero quiénes son esas personas que
empezaron a sentirse atraídas por el
discurso de la extrema derecha y Es que
además de aquellos que han sido
tradicionalmente conservadores o de
derechas este tipo de discursos tienen
un público muy concreto suelen ser
personas vulnerables como jóvenes o
gente en situación de desempleo que se
sienten aisladas y sienten la necesidad
de pertenecer a un grupo que pueda
convertir ese sentimiento de
insatisfacción en Esperanza un contexto
en el que los grupos radicales llegan
para llenar esa sensación de vacío y
promocionar su discurso de odio con
violencia de diferente tipo desde
comentarios racistas o machistas hasta
incluso agresiones físicas
en el caso de Brasil se han visto este
tipo de comportamientos durante la
última campaña presidencial con crímenes
claramente radicales uno de los más
sonados el de un bolsonarista que mató a
tiros a un vecino durante su cumpleaños
por llevar una camiseta de Lula da Silva
y como este muchísimos otros para
propagar este discurso de odio los
principales altavoces suelen ser las
redes sociales o los mismos grupos de
extrema derecha A través de
manifestaciones en el caso de La
retórica concreta de extrema derecha de
Jair bolsonaro captó a ciudadanos que se
autodefinen como gente de bien y que se
posicionan contra el comunismo o lo que
denominan como ideología de género
veamos algunos de sus argumentos
al presidente bolsonaro porque
representaba la esperanza de mantener el
país en la dirección correcta
y de apartar a nuestro pueblo de un
posible socialismo comunismo que
lamentablemente vemos en los países
vecinos
países
el trabajador quiere trabajar y también
soñar
Cómo vas a trabajar y Soñar en un
sistema que te da un salario muy pequeño
y quiere liberalizar las drogas y el
aborto
cada uno
cada uno piensa en su ombligo Entonces
votan por algún motivo los artistas
votaron por un motivo las emisoras los
periodistas votaron por otro motivo cada
uno tiene su propio interés cada uno
en Brasil la extrema derecha va mucho
más allá de bolsonaro pero sí está
relacionada con entre 2019 y 2021 se ha
registrado un aumento de los crímenes de
carácter apológico al nazismo un período
que coincide con su mandato Aquí vemos
publicados en los principales medios de
comunicación del país este tipo de
sucesos desde un menor con ideas nazis
que asesinó a cuatro de sus compañeros
en el colegio hasta amenazas de muerte e
incluso asesinatos a políticos
Especialmente militantes del partido de
los trabajadores en Brasil hay al menos
530 grupos neonazis como vemos aquí en
este mapa registrados con unas Diez mil
personas involucradas movimientos que
han crecido nada más y nada menos que en
un 270 por ciento en los últimos tres
años especialmente en el sur del país la
zona con más migración Europea y donde
hay más gente blanca con nosotros Odilio
en caldeira profesor de historia
contemporánea y experto en extrema
derecha para ayudarnos a entender la
presencia la importancia de estas
células neonazis en Brasil bienvenido
odilón los grupos neonazis o de extrema
derecha han estado siempre presentes en
el país
los movimientos de extrema derecha como
el neonazismo consiguen prominencia
política a lo largo de la última década
y sobre todo a lo largo de los últimos
años justo con la llegada de Yahir
bolsonaro al poder está claro que muchos
de esos grupos tienen algunas
diferencias puntuales o profundas con el
proyecto político de bolsonaro El
bolsonarismo es una expresión de la
extrema derecha brasileña pero no es la
única vez
Entonces en ese sentido los grupos de
extrema derecha consiguen dialogar con
sectores del bolsonalismo y en esa
coyuntura política más propicia aumenta
la propagación de los ideales de la
extrema derecha llevados A la práctica
política tanto su discurso como sus
ideas base y esos grupos consiguen más
presencial
entonces para resumir hay un proceso de
maduración de la extrema derecha
brasileña a lo largo de las últimas
décadas pero también hay una cultura
política propicia que da un terreno para
la articulación de sus grupos para
articulaciones
empiezan a sentir cierta legitimidad en
sus propuestas y reivindicaciones justo
porque Brasil se vuelve un exponente
global de la extrema derecha
centrándonos ahora un poco en las
contramedidas en las contramedidas Cómo
crees que se pueden combatir estos
movimientos neonazis
mapear entender observar en cierta
medida combatir la articulación de
grupos de extrema derecha se vuelve un
proceso de vigilancia constante
igual que la necesidad de entender esas
redes ya no es como era en la década de
los 80 que estos grupos organizaban en
torno a negacionistas del holocausto o
grandes tribus urbanas como los
o el poder blanco
ahora el movimiento o la articulación
incluso las figuras que articulan y
planifican los actos más violentos
muchas veces se presentan de una forma
desconectada Incluso como Los Lobos
solitarios Entonces es necesario pensar
en una estructura de acompañamiento
cotidiano de esos grupos tu derecho
respecto a la responsabilidad de los
medios de comunicación Cómo debe tratar
la prensa y la televisión este tipo de
información Es sobre neonazis y extrema
derecha en general
muchas veces
existen coberturas que dan espacio a las
figuras de la extrema derecha el
periodismo de declaraciones con la
búsqueda de un debate entre figuras
defensoras de los derechos humanos y
grupos que son fundamentalmente
contrarios a los derechos humanos
en este sentido pensar un espacio
mediático de la extrema derecha tiene un
espacio para verbalizar su discurso
acaba en cierta medida legitimizando Y
naturalizando estos preceptos políticos
e ideológicos
esto es necesario Entonces es necesario
que los medios de comunicación tengan la
defensa de la democracia y de los
Derechos Humanos como imperativo para
dar espacio y hacer cobertura mediática
o dilo Muchísimas gracias gracias por
estar con nosotros y es que justo esta
violencia como forma de expresiones el
legado más claro del bolsonarismo muchos
bolsonaristas no quieren adaptarse a los
marcos democráticos y se niegan a
reconocer las elecciones del 30 de
octubre personas que tienen muchas
posibilidades de ser asimiladas por
otros movimientos de extrema derecha
como el mismo neonazismo una extrema
derecha que parece va a sobrevivir al
mismo bolsonaro Valeria sakone y amín
cuidara nos amplían sobre el veamos
[Aplausos]
están acampados frente al cuartel
militar del ejército de Río de Janeiro
desde el inicio de noviembre
protestan contra la victoria de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva y las elecciones
pero cada semana hay menos gente aquí no
queremos no queremos un ladrón como
presidente
el tipo era un simple funcionario y de
repente él y sus hijos acumularon una
fortuna que casi ningún presidente tiene
un brasileño
una información desmentida por los
principales sitios de verificación de
noticias tampoco pudo demostrarse ningún
fraude electoral el informe de las
fuerzas armadas descartó esa posibilidad
pero los bolsonaristas aún defienden esa
tesis
Sólo queremos transparencia en el
proceso electoral Necesitamos saber
quién fue elegido realmente
en algunos casos las protestas derivaron
en violencia como ocurrió en Brasilia el
día en que Lula recibió el título de
presidente en el tribunal superior
electoral para esta politóloga el
bolsonarismo Todavía es muy fuerte y en
las últimas semanas se ha
retroalimentado gracias al silencio de
Jair bolso
este movimiento radical autoritario que
él ayudó a crear no va a acabar ahora él
Entonces yo creo que el bolsonarismo
sobrevivirá al propio bolsonaro A lo
mejor Tendremos que cambiarle el nombre
en los próximos meses se comprobará si
bolsonaro se convierte en el líder de la
posición fuera del parlamento o si surge
otra figura emblemática en la extrema
derecha brasileña que consiga opacarlo
Muchas gracias a todos los que han
colaborado con este especial y a ustedes
por su atención para esta y más
información es síganos en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]